[Musique]
je vais jamais parce qu'il se trouve que
j'aurais dit oui nous a fait nous
battons pas moi il se trouve que j'ai
enquêté sur ce chèque à sortir nos
masques ou peu voilà l'aï les princesses
oui tu as raison mais c'est pas ça la
vraie nouveauté c'est que tout le monde
croit que sa mère est française de
l'amour et moi mais vous avez ce qu'ils
veulent faire une révolution totale avec
les princes et les princesses de lamouri
lors quatre hommes quatre filles parce
qu'ils veulent parce qu'il trouve qu'il
ya passé une histoire d'amour au sein
des princes des places de l'amour dont
km les princes et les princesses c'est
grâce à elles auront le droit de faire
classe la seconde fois que j'avais une
version féminine des moins mais c'est
une pièce annexe heures annuelles a
[Rires]
accusé le scoop version fine des princes
de l'amour et et ça va être
monteyne sa star donc cl montaigne elle
est très belle avenue et voilà on est
bien on l'embrassé pour lancer the
nation je connais 202 à deuxième scoop
gratuit non mais vous vous lancez pas
payant vous allez aussi bien expliqué
que le premier combat le prenais c'est
pas une version finistère sont mixtes je
vous le dis vous verrez on deuxième
scoop
vu le succès des marseillais qui écrase
un peu les anges quand il marche
beaucoup mieux que les anges
il ya pas mal de candidats des anges qui
sont en train de retourner leur veste et
de gros pour leurs contrastes hérémence
allait partir faire les marchés et dans
le package et les marseillais et les
princes de l'amour je reconnais 2 je
peux pas le dire encore ça s'est fait
dans ce cas les voies et c'est ça la
fout oui ça c'est une [ __ ] d'infos
[Rires]
moi personnellement je m'en fous
totalement fausses et qu'il a dîné avec
eux en fait masser sa mère soit vous
êtes avec qui reçoit avec justement des
candidats la dieldrine des bagarres et
n'auront jamais on va savoir qui va
gamaret paga non mais y avait le raid
amaury lido trouvons qu'était la
ballerine là avec son nouveau mec dont
je ne peux pas dire de nom qui est un
enjeu et qui va partir des angles vraie
adresse content de savoir que tu es une
tombe comme on l'appelle
nous tenons ce n'est pas tim arrêté
diabate au monde sait qu'ils aient
sommet compas dans sa maladie peut pas
moi de moi je sais les marseillais je
les aime bien mais je m'en fous
totalement de cette émission
oui mais c'est là où était la subtilité
jouer le garder en coupe les consignes
au contraire il songe et inique ce sont
ces baptêmes or ils sont copains qui
font son man c'était une bataille quand
ils font l'émission troisième scoop
[Applaudissements]
ça finit par payer
[Rires]